new emails appear to shed light on
Laurie Lachlan and Massimo Jian Ellie's
alleged involvement in the College
Admission scandal these documents 484
documents that were released both from
Laurie Lachlan as well as her husband
Massimo is absolutely bad news the
fuller house star and her husband are
accused of paying $500,000 in bribes to
get their daughters admitted to USC as
recruits for the crew team even though
neither of them had ever participated in
the sport I think the likelihood that
Laurie spends prison time is very very
high because of the seriousness of the
crime and the amount of money that we're
dealing with here according to the 480
plus documents disclosed by prosecutors
on Tuesday a USC official was in touch
with Massimo in September 2016 and
according to prosecutors appeared to be
trying to court the fashion designer for
a potential donation the USC official
emailed Massimo to check in and see if
his daughter planned on continuing with
the admissions process at USC the
official also offered to set up a
one-on-one customized tour of the campus
adding quote I'd also be happy to flag
her application in the government's
filing on Tuesday Erica Rosen an
assistant US attorney argued that Laurie
and Massimo specifically rejected this
legitimate approach in favour of working
with the scandals alleged ringleader
William Rick's singer and in a statement
to the New York Times USC denied that
what they offered to Massimo was special
or unique quote the primary purpose of a
flag is to be able to track the outcome
of the admission review process it is
not a substitute for otherwise being
qualified for admission to USC in August
2016 a month before the unnamed USC
official reached out an email exchange
allegedly shows that Rick had started
the process of securing Isabella's
admission into college requesting
Isabella's test scores and transcripts
as well as a picture of her on an indoor
rowing machine quote in workout clothes
like a real athlete
Massimo a USC alum himself allegedly
wrote back fantastic we'll get all the
tried to sign up as a Coxon someone who
steers the boat tried to get her to have
pictures of her and an ERG and this is
all done an email communications that
showed that they were trying to build
literally a portfolio to show that she
was quote a real athlete fast forward
one month to that email from USC to
Massimo offering to flag his daughter's
application he responded thanks so much
I think we are squared away what you're
seeing here is evidence that shows not
only did Lori know that this was a scam
and Massimo was seems to be an integral
part of this scam but they also had the
ability to go about it the right way it
shows not only a consciousness of guilt
that this was wrong but also that they
completely knew that this was a scam
Isabella was eventually admitted into
the university and her younger sister
Olivia was admitted the following year I
want them to be happy so I want to be
supportive of everything they want to do
but I do want them to have somewhat of a
normal you know finish out of high
school college experience maybe because
I didn't have that I would really want
that for them during Olivia's admission
process the University's Dean of
Admissions flagged Donna heinel a
high-ranking administrator in the
athletic department asking her to look
into quote a couple of students whose
high schools were quite surprised to
hear they were being admitted as
athletic recruits Donna was later
arrested and accused of orchestrating
her part of the college admissions scam
she has pleaded not guilty to conspiracy
to commit racketeering bribery and fraud
the documents also appear to show that
for each of his daughters
Massimo allegedly wrote out a check to
the University for fifty thousand
dollars to an account controlled by
Donna and paid two hundred thousand
dollars to key worldwide foundation a
shell charity allegedly run by Rick for
a total of five hundred thousand dollars
both Massimo and Lori have pleaded not
guilty to all charges leveled against
them in the College Admission scandal I
just want them to have that experience
and get that education and
a degree to fall back on of course you
can count on et to bring you all the
latest on this developing story so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]